la Star Academy est de retour une star
ac nouvelle génération nouveau corps
professoral nous beaux élèves mais
toujours la même soif de musique de
spectateur quelqu'un sait déjà timide un
truc dans le Hulk en fait
on n'a pas on n'a pas une heure et demie
pour le truc que tu t'es mis la tenté de
citer le dernier slogan gouvernemental
je baisse j'éteins je décale mais là
encore fichu problème de languette
Apéricube à partir du slogan je suis pas
très bien compris j'ai essayé de le
répéter je vais je baise je
décale je recale je non je baisse oui je
baisse c'est ça ouais en fait blague à
part il y a quand même eu de
l'amélioration ça il faut se le mettre
se le mettre en tête
[Rires]
vous avez souvent fait fort Boyard Eve
trois fois trois fois Fort Boyard et
j'ai ignorais que dans Fort Boyard il y
avait une épreuve de sodo et ça non
[Rires]
pardon bonjour
que je l'aurais jamais dû quitter
tout le monde veut savoir alors je
raconte parce que il est à la fois noble
et pas noble le panobe c'est que je
voulais prendre de l'essence hier soir
pour être prêt soit aujourd'hui pour
l'émission 2h30 que je passe à côté j'ai
quand même ça au-delà de mes forces
j'irai de maillots
elle a même fait plus de cette fois
dans la même minute
[Applaudissements]
faut record c'est 4
des gens des médias qui m'envoient leurs
piques c'est à dire leur photo de partie
intime il y a des stars qui t'envoient
leurs
animateurs des gens dans la politique je
reçois et je leur dis mais heureusement
que je suis cortiquée parce que je
pourrais balancer la photo alors moi je
pense aussi je pense que ça pourrait
m'abîmer moi aussi dans ma carrière le
fait de les de diverger
ma plus grosse trahison c'est assez
terrible mais c'est mes productrices de
des amours c'est des gens à qui j'ai
travaillé pendant près de 20 ans et au
moment où il a fallu sacrifier ils m'ont
jeter au feu c'est assez incroyable ce
qu'on appelle
c'est surtout ce qu'on appelle une mise
au pied de gens pour quitte à travailler
alors ça arrive pas qu'à la télé c'est
pour ça que je m'emmerde on en parle
d'une manière générale c'est c'est quand
même très surpris et surpris aussi d'un
truc c'est que vous êtes petit
chroniqueur je suis énorme star je ne
reçois aucune photo de top de la Mairie
de Paris en sortant pas forcément de
Paris je me dis si oui mais même de la
mairie de Montpellier
mais j'en sais rien vous enchaînez avec
Jacques LeBron il est stylé et moi je
suis content c'est rare de voir des
légendes de TF1 qui ont pas touché de
femme donc vraiment je suis content que
que vous soyez là non mais c'est vrai
parce que ça me fait plaisir
il faut le dire quand même on va donner
des nouvelles de nos deux députés French
French Lover hein j'ai envie de dire
Adrien catenas n'est pas revenu Daniel
balle du siège mais c'est normal parce
que Damien bad n'a jamais levé le
moignon sur sa compagne
22 ans tu as quel âge a zen j'ai 20 ans
qui a dit 22 ans régie mais qu'est-ce
qui s'est planté en régie hein je vais
tirer l'oreille de Mathieu perron avec
Anne Marcassus tire-lui l'oreille la
productrice t'es sûr que tu as 20 ans
pourquoi avoir été voilà être
je perds mes mots aussi ce matin comment
pourquoi
en fait ce livre il est
[Rires]
qu'est-ce qui vous relie à ce que vous
êtes en tant qu'artiste ici dans cette
émission
ce qui me relie j'ai pas bien compris la
question
de la politique c'est tu leur dis est-ce
que quel jour tu préfères sur les 7
jours de la semaine je sais pas écouter
le lundi le lundi c'est vrai que le
lundi est chouette mais le mardi à ses
avantages
la réponse en réalité c'est pas me le
but c'est pas de vous attaquer de toutes
parts mais c'est vrai la question elle
est simple est-ce que ça vous choque oui
ou non donc je vais vous répondre mais
vous pouvez entendre que le mardi
la boîte à sel en fait c'est quelque
chose qui se trouvait dans une salle de
théâtre dans toutes les salles de
théâtre au cas où quelqu'un est un
malaise et on lui donnait des selles
quand la personne s'évanouissait le
titre de cette émission vient de de ça
voilà j'aurais pu penser au sucre pour
un coup de Mouk au sel mais bon
la boîte à sel et pour certaines élèves
ce tour de chauffe devient carrément en
exercice à haut risque
[Musique]
heureusement plus de peur que de mal
vous avez suivi l'émission on aimerait
votre réaction à chaud là alors oui j'ai
regardé le château ils ont repeints
est super quoi vraiment moi j'avais très
envie de la regarder la Star Ac au lieu
de regarder notre émission ah mais comme
tout le monde
[Rires]
à fond moi j'ai été attiré direct bonne
soirée merci beaucoup ce fut un plaisir
voilà